Well his work,
um,
that DVD series that he did magical Egypt
was amazing and I had seen your work
before that in that mysteries of the
Sphinx thing that was narrated by Charlton
Heston,
Heston and Basei 1993,
I think in many ways it was the
mystery of the Sphinx that really broke
everything open. It brought
everything to the public attention.
I've had many people tell me,
I'm not trying to brag or anything,
I'm just saying factually that this really
opened up a new field if we could put
it that way. A new, um, you know,
way of looking at things in the
popular, among the popular, um,
public crash,
the popular media that,
but people around the world versus the
academic scholarly journals and the back
and forth, that type of thing. You
have to remember, I'm a faculty member,
I'm at Boston University and my academic,
uh,
and many of the academics have poo pooed
should we say over the years bringing
things to the public.
But I think it's been important to do.
Now what we're talking about
for the people that are
uninformed is the idea that
some of the structures in ancient Egypt
are far older than conventional wisdom
or conventional modern day archeology,
modern day egyptologist.
They would like us to believe that all
of this spawned from a very specific time
period and people like John Anthony West
and yourself and some other folks like
Graham Hancock are proposing that it's
entirely possible that there were many
different era's of construction in Egypt
and that there were some structures
that are far, far older than
we think. Yeah, exactly.
And this what I was alluding to is
this really opened up with our work on
redating, the Great Sphinx,
and I think you know the story,
but maybe just to summarize it
in the smallest of nutshells,
John Anthony West,
before I met him, he was,
became a follower,
should we say,
or I shouldn't say follower
because that sounds wrong,
but sounds like it's a religion dogma.
But he became interested in the work of
the late Schwaller de Lubitsch who died
passed away in 1961 but he had mentioned
in a one line that does things had been
weathered by rain,
I would say precipitation as a geologist,
not wind and sand. So this, if
it were true and it is true,
would put the Sphinx back
to a much earlier period,
which would tie in with [inaudible]
work and John Anthony West.
His subsequent work that there were
indications that dynastic Egypt as we know
it,
going back to about 3000 BC was really a
legacy of what I call now earlier cycle
of civilization. A something that
goes back much, much earlier,
which at this point I date back
to the end of the last ice age.
I say Chen at 9,700 BC.
Just to put it in perspective for people.
So when,
when did you first get on board with this?
Hi John Anthony West. Come to
you or John? Anthony West. Okay,
so the story goes this way. John Anthony
West published serpent in the sky.
His probably most famous book,
First Edition 1979 he was then looking
for someone that could really validate or
at least assess from a
scientific point of view,
this theory about this Sphinx,
which he had just barely sort of
touched the surface based on Schwaller.
That may be, it could be older, but
this was really a geological question.
He mentioned that in 1979
and serpent in the sky,
John Anthony West went on to become
very involved with Egypt and he start
traveling to Egypt.
He led tourists to Egypt.
He wrote the travelers key to ancient
Egypt in 1985 also mentions in appendix,
I think it was just the
older sphinx theory,
but really looking for someone to
at least assess it scientifically.
He met a fellow at in,
um,
in Egypt actually at the time,
Robert [inaudible] who is a
phd in English literature,
I believe,
something like that,
but he was teaching in Cairo and
American University in Cairo, I believe.
Then he came to Boston University.
This is late 1980s I was and still do
teach at Boston University full time.
Robert, Eddie and myself. Got
To know each other. Robert,
Eddie mentioned me as a geologist to
John Anthony West and that may be,
this was someone who seemed
fairly knowledgeable,
fairly open minded about things in time.
Did you have any rules
on Egypt or, oh, I, I I,
my interest in Egypt goes way back.
I was reading about ancient Egypt when
I was literally six seven eight years
old.
I had a grandmother who had a wonderful
library at the time and I would go
through her library shit books from the
British Museum on ancient Egypt going
back to the turn of the century,
so I was prepared in a sense
I was open to such things,
but I didn't imagine getting involved
in Egypt in any way professionally.
Did you have any thoughts about the
dating of the Sphinx or the pyramids or
anything back then?
There were two things,
so there were two things
going on in my head back then,
which may be prepped me for this. Number
One, I knew the conventional story.
I knew that this things goes back to
2,500 BC according to the standard
Egyptologists in 1989
which is when I first,
I believe it was 1989 I first
actually met western person.
I had in my mind that the egyptologist
must be correct because they've studied
it.
They must know what they're doing.
I was coming from an academic
point of view. I um, I'm not,
I'm just giving, you know,
saying where I'm coming from.
I had gone to Yale University to get
my phd in Geology and geophysics.
I was very well grounded in quote,
the status quo academic point of view.
So I thought when I first went to Egypt,
I would just prove west wrong.
I would just prove that the egyptologist
knew what they were talking about. But,
and this is an important,
but I was also trained in many ways,
both as a graduate student and going
back to my grandmother who I had great
respect for and was also very,
should we say liberal and
open minded but critical.
You always have to follow the
evidence wherever it goes.
And that's always been my rule thumb,
that not everything is always the way
people say it is even if they're quote
authorities.
And something I already knew when I went
to Egypt for the first time was that
some of the very old
egyptologist in the late 19th,
early 20th century had actually
suggested that just the way it looks,
the feel of the Sphinx,
not based on hard evidence really that
may be, it was older than the pyramids.
That may be,
it goes back earlier.
So I felt that it wasn't all
said and done and you know,
pat and sound that the egyptologist
necessarily knew what they were talking
about in modern times because some of the
earlier Egyptologists who they held in
very high respect supposedly had
set different things. Secondly,
and I hate to bring this up, but I will
because it's part of the background. I,
my grandmother, who I
mentioned a second ago, uh,
was a theosophist and Thea,
if you know anything about theosophy,
it also suggests that,
you know,
maybe there's things that go back earlier.
I don't,
what is the theosophy theosophy this,
it's, it's a, how do I explain it?
You have you heard of Blavatsky
Madame Blavatsky? No. Okay.
Whoop.
I'm losing my headphones.
Theosophy was founded in
the late 19th century.
It questioned a lot of
the materialistic values,
a lot of the dogma of Science,
of the time, of religion,
of the time it looked to the east
in particular to other philosophies,
other worldviews.
So basically it was a way,
this is what it did for me at least.
And I'm not a theosophist,
I don't want to say I'm a theosophist.
Uh,
but reading theosophical works on
top of everything else allowed me,
I think to expand my horizons and to see
that maybe the dogma of the day is just
that the dogma of the day,
that there are other possibilities.
And not that we accept something just
because someone said it or it because it's
old or because it's this religion or
that religion or that supposed to be
ancient culture. But no,
you keep everything open.
You look at the evidence,
and that's really where I was coming from.
But my point is that even in late 1980s
early 1990s when I first got involved
with this,
if I looked at it critically,
the evidence was not that definitive
for the age of the Sphinx.
So I was going in with
open mind at possibilities.
But honestly,
when I first went to Egypt
with John Anthony West in
1990 I thought before I got
off the plane that this would be simple,
open and shut case.
I would prove him wrong in the sense of
his assertions that may be the Sphinx
was older.
I had no doubt at the time that my
colleagues in Egyptology must know what
they're talking about.
And all of that changed literally
within 30 without exaggerating,
30 to 120 seconds of foreseen
reasonings. Yeah, it really did.
It was really big impression because my
first impression of the spanx was now
that I saw it on the ground in person,
there was something wrong with the Egypt
to logical dating because when you look
at the Sphinx as a geologist
with a geological I,
this was not weathered by wind and sand,
this was not desert erosion.
And weathering that I saw on the sinks,
the body of the Sphinx,
which is very difficult to tell because
it's been heavily repaired and reworked,
but particularly on the walls of what
are known as the Sphinx enclosure.
The Sphinx enclosure is important because
it preserves a lot of the details and
if you haven't,
if the audience has not been to Egypt,
they should realize that when they carved
the Sphinx, it's all solid bedrock.
Only the head initially was above
the ground surface. You carved,
they carved down into the rock to
free up the body, what I call it,
the core body of the Sphinx in it's
that core body and the walls of the
enclosure,
more or less the quarry around it,
if you want to use that term that show
these ancient weathering precipitation
erosional features that are incompatible
with the last 5,000 years of climatic
history on the eastern edge of the Sahara.
So immediately I knew there was something
wrong geologically had to figure that
out.
Either this was a weird geological
anomaly or something else was going on and
the Sphinx might go back
to earlier period. Also,
I want to point out that when you look
at the Sphinx and other geologists have
looked at this as well,
they did not just chip away at the
rock to carve the body. More or less,
you could have chipped away at the rock
with pick axes and that type of thing.
Shoveled out chips of rock in baskets.
That would've been the easy way.
What they did is they carved
out huge blocks of stone,
and when I say huge, we're
talking multitenant, tens of tons.
Some of them may be over 50
tons or more of limestone.
They move those due east of the Sphinx
and built what is now known as the Sphinx
Temple, which is still there in ruinous
condition and the valley temple.
So you had these two huge
temples and what is interesting,
a lot of people don't realize
this or they don't think about,
I think those constructions which are
contemporary with the oldest portion of
the Sphinx in some ways
are more impressive.
If you think about the technology
and what went into constructing them.
Then the age of the Sphinx itself.
So it's not just the Sphinx,
it's also these limestone temples
that are associated with it.
And we're built contemporaneously.
So Jamie pulled up two photos here of
the first one that he pulled up was a
computer image that showed
the Sphinx and showed a,
I'm looking at it now. Yes. And,
and in this image, what you can see,
that's a computer image that's
actually from mystery of this fakes.
And then there's a inset that's an
aerial photograph, the real thing.
And that shows how when
they were carving the body,
they cut out huge blocks and then put
them in position to make what's known as
the Sphinx Temple due east of the Sphinx.
And the second image is the Sphinx Temple.
You look at this,
it says the Sphinx faces due east,
the rising sun and right in front
of it is this Sphinx Temple.
So this is a humongous temple made
out of these huge blocks of stone,
which were carved out when they
carved the body of the Sphinx.
And here you see in this image
another picture of the Sphinx Temple.
And so these erosion,
if you can see they are,
you can see how big they
are. They're enormous. Okay.
These are ocean features on the blocks.
Don't worry about them for the moment.
Okay, let's go back to the
Sphinx enclosure itself.
It's a sphinx enclosure where
you see the rolling undulating,
profiled the Roche no features here.
You see it in that picture,
the vertical fissures.
And I know you're familiar with this
personally because I've heard you talk
about it with John Anthony West.
That can only be caused by precipitation.
The rocks are like a layer cake,
so takes out the software layers,
it receipts, um, the software layer sound,
the hardware layer stick out further,
but the water also finds its
way down crevices and cracks,
natural features that are slightly softer
in it forms these vertical fissures.
I wanna make the point because a lot
of people get confused. They say,
couldn't it be rising Nile
floods? No. Geologically,
that would give a very different
signature on the rockets,
not floods coming up from the bottom.
It's actually precipitation and rainfall
runoff coming from above and rainfall
over thousands of years. Well,
there's two aspects here.
It could be thousands of years,
it could be much stronger rainfall,
you know,
huge flash floods,
that type of thing.
And part of the story that I hope we'll
get to is that initially I'm jumping
around here a little bit,
but initially I was thinking five to
7,000 BC that was very conservative based
on the geological data, based on the
seismic, which we have to get to also.
But now I believe we're talking prior to
9,700 BC for the original construction
of this things and we can talk about why
the dating and at 9,700 BC we have the
end of the younger Dryas,
the end of the glacial epoch,
the end of the last ice age.
I have now put together the story based
on evidence and when I ever see I say if
I say I believe something
or I think something,
it's always based on evidence that I've
been piecing together that what we had
ending the younger dryas ending the last
ice age was a huge eruption from the
sun, a huge solar outbursts,
huge climatic changes,
which put among other things
a lot of precipitation,
a law of moisture into the air,
which came down as precipitation
with huge floods, huge,
um, essentially thunderstorms, et cetera.
And I think a lot of the initial erosion
that we still see on the walls of the
things enclosure,
go back to that period.
So you had the situation where you
would get this incredible weathering and
erosion and then it continued for
thousands of years after that and was
reinforced until you had the Sahara
coming in in relatively recent times and
geologically Holocene Times
desert the Sahara desert.
So before that it was some
sort of a rain forest. Ah,
it's Savannah to rainforest.
It actually varied over time.
And before that it was very fertile.
Savannah,
lots of plants there.
People have seen it,
even in popular movies and whatnot,
how the Sahara at one point had
water and all kinds of animals.
That's before the end of the last ice age,
before this,
these incredible changes
that we have at 9,700 BC.
So that's where, um, the Sphinx,
I think the original Sphinx
goes back to that time period.
And that's what the Egyptians called Zep
Tepi this was a first time for them or
what I call an earlier cycle of
civilization. The last cycle,
the one that we're still
part of in my terminology,
is the last 5,000 years.
So civilization arising re-emerging I
should say about 3000 to 4,000 BC coming
into really what we have now is,
you know, high technology, etc.
But before that there
had been earlier cycles,
civilization that was essentially
snuffed out or brought to its knees,
if you would,
by the end of the last ice age.
And just to map this out,
a period from about 9,700 BC,
this is what I'm reconstructing now to
about 4,000 to 3000 BC where we have
civilization reemerging
between that period.
So thousands of years,
9,700 BC to say 3,700
BC for round numbers,
6,000 years.
We have essentially a dark period.
And what I've been now calling siddha
solar induced dark age sort of ironic,
the sun will induce a dark age because
of brought civilization back to an
earlier stage if you would. I'm
just not sure I follow that. Well,
how did the son do this? Um,
solar outburst, essentially
coronal mass ejection,
huge eruption,
bigger than anything we've ever
seen on earth and mas is massive.
Thunder showers and we
exactly new modern history.
Modern history is even close to this,
but we do have isotope data,
et cetera.
That indicates this has happened in the
past at the end of the last ice age and
I'm sure it's happened many times over
and you have a lot of markers that
indicate this. You have vitrification of
rock. Um, in fact, a lot of the markers,
and I don't want to be
debating the issue necessarily,
but a lot of the markers that people
have used for a comment at the younger,
dry ice or during the
younger dryas through a,
most of them are at the
beginning of the younger dryas.
That's what they're claiming. But of
the, uh, a lot of the dating is very,
very iffy. Um, I found it
interesting. For instance,
someone will use something as a marker
for the younger dry ice and that will
give a date of 12,000 plus
or minus 4,000 years. So,
you know, this is just
the way geology is, but.